welcome back to big mood
yeah i almost wanted to say where we
talk about whatever we want
whatever we want
and today i found some um
articles well actually i found one and
our producer over here helped find
another one
um it's about dating profiles things you
should not put on your dating profiles i
know that this summer is gonna be a hot
back
summer oh yeah and people are gonna be
out there getting [ __ ] hop back
so um it's been a long time it's been a
while since
people have seen people and dates and
waxed yes and now everyone is vaccinated
and ready to get stds and so i wanted to
get relaxed
ready to help date your dating profile
online dating is
pretty rough as it is but if you have a
shitty profile it could probably be even
worse
yeah and people make yeah give yourself
the best shot
you know if dating is already hard don't
shoot yourself in the foot
right off the jump and so to be fair
i've got a listicle
of things that girls say turn them off
from the men's profiles and the thing
that
men say turn them off from women's
profiles because we like to be
fair fair on this show i guess
just hating it just hating it no i'm not
like
i'm just kidding i'm kidding the women
should be held accountable as well
um so we can start uh with some of the
stuff that the girls said that they
didn't like
well let's start there let's get angry
let's get angry first
where i exist
[Laughter]
um the first one is when men list making
money with just dollar signs under the
my profession box i don't understand are
you printing out counterfeit bills
that's code where i live with my mom i
get an allowance right
to me it's like they think women are
fish with
you know they only see gold [ __ ]
objects so they're like putting
dollar signs on their profile like all
you care about it's money right i'm
making money don't worry about what i
don't worry about
about sweetheart yeah sweetheart i'm
making money you know what else do you
want
like but it's probably something
embarrassing like yeah you know so they
don't want to say but i'm like just say
if you're a plumber that's great just
say you're the hot dog on a stick yeah
what
don't worry about it or they're drunk
it's
probably that they're a drug dealer or
some sort of tax scam or just some [ __ ]
you're like i'm a professional poker
player yeah yeah where you're like
i sell herbalife i sell herbalife oh god
if it's a pyramid scheme
oh the other people are the ones that
put running my own business yeah
[Music]
yeah don't do that just put your what
your job is and if it's something [ __ ]
up then sorry i can't help you because
you're changing you're ashamed of it
isn't there like an option to leave
certain ones blank
you can but it might be weird or i don't
know
yeah which one's worse blank or dollar
signs dollar signs
thousands is definitely worse you could
actually put thought into
just entrepreneur without saying like if
you're not like probably one percent of
people that write entrepreneur
in their bio are actual entrepreneurs
because there's not that many real ones
there's a lot of fake ones
so don't write that either yeah if you
like i don't know just don't spring it
up in if it's something you gotta
explain like i get cause like our things
kind of like i feel like i kind of have
to explain it i'm like
kind of a youtuber but kind of also
don't write aspiring
like if you're an artist don't really
aspiring writer
or aspiring actor it just sounds like
you don't know what you're doing and
you're
you're not you're not professional at
all
yeah don't do that mm-hmm that doesn't
turn me off as much as
it does for me it means entrepreneur
like you could just be sleeping in
on the couch all day long and you're an
aspiring writer
because you're dreaming of one day being
being a writer someday you're not
actually a writer then
yeah true i mean i guess i could see it
as like they know that they're not quite
somewhere yet but they're
working towards a goal so i mean i could
see how you don't like it you're a
writer or you're not a writer
okay it's just better than someone being
like i'm the [ __ ] ceo of my own
business
no you're not yeah on a tier of most
losery
i'd say the ceo of own business is lower
than aspiring writer
but they're still bad both of them i
could give them a little bit of a
benefit out if they're still striving
for a goal as long as they're actually
striving for that goal but
that's cute anyway
yeah i didn't expect that from jess me
neither that's a surprise
the word aspiring doesn't bother me but
yeah losers do bother me
okay next one i have seen so many guys
put things like rest in peace to my
grandma
june 2017 because yeah tinder is totally
the place to remember your deceased
grandmother
do that i feel like they try to do
something like that because i'm a family
yeah
like maybe if she feels bad for me
she'll suck my dick i don't know oh
that's gross
yeah it's kind of weird so yeah maybe
don't talk about
like something sad like on your profile
it's a pity party for you yeah where
you're trying to like getting empathy
points cuz like why would that need to
be
like because tender so like just [ __ ]
based
shallow shallow yeah that like why would
you put that
there that's so strange yeah that is
really weird
um anything people put that on their
cars too what
like you know on the back of their cars
mexican yeah a lot of ours would be like
rest in peace a lot of my people do that
yeah
yeah i get that though because they have
like the family
pride thing like the okay
it's a big part of their life i guess it
makes sense if they're like well why
people post how many
family members they have that's weird
too
because you know we have dia de los
muertos yeah so we're like
let's respect the dead i guess all car
decals to me look silly
okay it's weird that they have car
decals and t-shirts for dead people but
i still respect
the the idea behind it i'm like i'm not
going to forget my brother i'm not going
to absolutely i think
definitely honestly but if don't put it
on tender okay yeah
that's weird yeah i think it's weird
when people put their family on
the stickers on their cars with all the
names okay i know all your kids names
yeah
yeah it's like my child's an honor
student like i know where your kid go to
school
yeah yeah yeah i think tom segura had a
joke about that and his stand up he's
like you're literally putting
you know advertising you're advertising
my child goes to this school
at this day he's like you play soccer
where can pedos pick him up right
that's funny um okay the next one is
anything that insinuates you're too good
to be
on insert the dating site if you were
really too good for tinder you wouldn't
be on tinder
what would be an example of that so i
think i've seen people were like well
you know i didn't really want to be here
but i'm just seeing you know like
they're like have to like you're here
excuse themselves for being here it's
like
yeah we all know this [ __ ] you came to
the party yeah you came into a halloween
party
in a regular outfit and you're like i
don't really do costumes
like you're not cooler exactly yeah yeah
i don't know
that's kind of um it just means that you
cure it just means that you
probably it makes me think oh you struck
out everywhere else and now it's like um
yeah i'm here i'm too good to be here
yeah but it's like it's a social
scene so i guess like it makes sense why
people are there even though
it's it is kind of embarrassing to be
there because there's a lot of shitty
situations and people and stuff that
comes from a place like tender or
i think it's embarrassing i think yeah
it's it's so normal now
yeah i don't know anyone that hasn't
been on it that other than people that
have been in a relationship for 10 years
yeah who missed the whole yeah we missed
it yeah i didn't miss
that whole window but um nowadays i feel
like every single single friend i have
is on there at some point some sort of
yeah dating
they go through waves where they're like
oh i deleted them all and then they go
back on
yeah yeah i think it kind of like brings
down the vibe of like
you know probably nine out of ten dates
you gone are gonna suck or whatever but
like
we're still trying to like make this a
fun thing so like why are you starting
it off with like i
can't get that i'm even here you know
like
then just don't be honest don't be here
like i deleted my apps because i was
like oh [ __ ] i'm sick of this [ __ ]
but but it's probably just because i
needed a break from it
but yeah like they're coming back like
hey
i'm back but i don't want to be better
than this but like yeah
yeah like who's going to swipe right on
that like i don't really like
being here i'm too good for this but i'm
judging anyone that's on here
yeah pretty much you can't judge someone
if you're there too
um oh and then the next one someone put
have usernames like bigdick34 oh god
what people like steve would do that i
don't know i would do it ironically
it is funny there's some sex pro sex
only profiles like guys who are like i'm
literally just here to [ __ ] so they make
it
so disgustingly like [ __ ] boy that
you're like
okay absolutely not i mean i guess
someone swipes on it yeah that's what i
was gonna say it makes it easier for the
people that they're targeting yeah to
find them
but for general public probably not a
good idea yeah but i think the guys who
do that probably know that too
like yeah they know to catch a girl that
they can't just be like
eat my dick 34. or
they know the type of girl that will
exactly i'm like
what if you're just in one of those
faces where you're like i'm gonna [ __ ]
the next [ __ ] boy
in early or late 2019 early 2020 i was
like give me all the dicks
there's this one guy that i swiped on
not because i wanted to date him but
then he said that i'm a wine
um like connoisseur like he's he works
in the winery business or whatever his
family owns he's like if you have any
questions about wine let me know and i
actually did have a legitimate question
because
i was wondering why when i record my
wine sometimes the cork just pops out
again oh yeah
so i messaged yeah so i was like hey
i have a question and i asked him about
that he goes are you going to send me
nudes or not
what i was like no dude i have a
question
and then then he answered him like all
right i don't even [ __ ] care anymore
i'm like yeah
what
also i wouldn't drink that one unless it
was a yeah like a champagne or something
like it really shouldn't be doing that
okay that doesn't sound right yeah it's
like i drink it right don't leave it out
yeah you probably drink that [ __ ] i
drank it i'm infertile now all right
but that's good for you i have a
legitimate question
yeah that guy has like zero game because
he's gonna use that yeah
and then got the nudes come on he's
probably 12. he's a grown-ass man
it's a grown-ass man he's like i don't
have time to talk to these [ __ ] well
that's why you don't got a [ __ ]
then don't put in your profile ask me
questions about wine like there's
whatever words and then the girl's like
oh [ __ ] i have to send a nude to get
this answer right
one question okay the bottom the lowest
of the lowest hanging fruits of girls
with the worst selfies
picture any girl doing that for a while
why would he do that i actually can but
not a literal nude it's like a photo of
like a nude
pelican because like if you were gonna
like it would be for money if you were
like that yeah type of
just like this send me money yeah not a
answer to a watch
and i'll [ __ ] send you my titties
when google exists
i'm sorry man yeah i could literally
google this but i was trying to flirt
with you
sorry i know what an idiot i wonder if
that's how he responds to all the girls
right probably stupid striking he's in a
standing in his own way
they're gonna say standing in his own
[ __ ] oh
no um the next one is just like a list
of words with emojis so like
god with prayer hands family with the
family emoji
ball with a basketball grind with a
money thing
gains with the [ __ ] like did you just
get an iphone you know like
it's not new like he doesn't he's a
boomer complete
sentences like you can't speak he's just
like yeah god ball
gains more yeah and you're like okay
ew eggplant peach i think that works for
yeah yeah i think that works
that probably works for young people
like that it just sounds like a very
immature thing to do
obviously i don't think great that's why
that's how i like to list my groceries
like you're like bananas banana emojis
adorable casey and i did it once because
we thought it was cute
because we have a shared note for
groceries and yeah we did that once but
i told you what happened to steve when i
gave him a list right
he copy pasted my list and then he
barely got any of the items because he
was like they don't have garlic
cucumbers and i'm like
what i asked
every single person that worked there
where the garlic cucumbers were
and they they don't have them they call
menological species
but i've seen so many instances of
midnight using their [ __ ] brain
or like some sort of rational thinking
that i'm like are you
kidding me yeah [ __ ] hilarious they
asked for
garlic and cucumbers holy [ __ ] that's
funny i have them they don't have a god
bless because they don't have this
anywhere
oh god i went to four stores i also have
to give him pictures of the type of
almond milk that i get because he can
never
bring the right one home and it's never
even with the pictures he can't
they all look the same oh my god
that's funny god bless him i love that
guy he's
one idiot i love him um i'll trust him
with crypto
yeah but not with gross groceries he
does shits on the emojis he does a bad
job so he doesn't have to do it anymore
no because he loves going to the grocery
store it's just bad out he's bad at it
okay yeah well he's got a lot of great
qualities yeah
i also have to give him specific brand
names otherwise he'll just buy him bulk
he'll buy like the whole box he's like
it's the deal
i don't want any of this i'm not eating
this the one ply
it's a better deal oh my god that
happened recently too casey bought
pickles
and they were the sweet pickles i'm like
i actually like sweets
yeah it's disgusting
don't put that in your bio i like sweet
pickles
yeah but but he was like yeah it was
cheaper oh my god he didn't know that
they were different places yeah
he left i don't think he noticed that
he's just looking he's like three
dollars
it's not inferior they're soft too i
like the crunch
same yeah yeah well you got to get the
right ones anyway you're too sweet
you know what i don't like this pickle
hating [ __ ] discussion right now
sweet part of my culture because we say
why people have culture we do and it's
sweet
it's bad garlic cucumbers however garlic
cucumbers
that's like the what is it korean or
japanese or something where they have
the like the meat
he's making reminds me of steve's garlic
cucumber no
but i'm just saying that sounds like now
you sound like steve i did it's like it
sounds like a real i thought it was a
thing because i was in the asian store i
was in nineteen
yeah joe used to eat that he would take
a big slab of miso
which i guess is kind of like that and
you would eat it with cucumbers so i
could see that being like
still two separate items yeah i'm still
two separate that is not an actual yeah
or they could be they could be marinated
cucumbers
stop defending this man you know what
did you even put a comma between
i i had them all spaced out like oh like
this okay there's no
then he copy pasted and i guess the line
spacing didn't work you're coming
together that's hilarious
well you know we still love him uh the
next one is
putting a quote in their bio about how
most women are crazy and how how he's
looking for a woman who isn't crazy
that's like really i'm not like the
other girls girl that's what i was
looking for
an in-law in logan and log that just
tells me like every single
person you pick was crazy right so it
means you're not ready to date because
that's what happened to me
every single person i was dating was
like a lying [ __ ]
you know what like just kind of leading
me on kind of an [ __ ] kind of and i'm
like well
yeah you're just you're picking the
wrong person every time
yeah you can't advertise you can't
advertise on your profile like i don't
want a crazy one it's like well
that's kind of what you're attracting so
that's that's your common denominator
yeah inside you yeah but also that might
help
as a woman looking at it i'm like oh i
like him oh [ __ ] i'm crazy i should go
to therapy
one can only it's still a deterrent for
a date and then i could win this man
no and then i'm like now i can find a
better man because i won't be picking
you
yeah i don't know it just sounds like
problems i feel like the crazy ones
don't recognize that they're crazy
yeah anyway so it's like oh me i'm not
i'm not crazy
yeah i should miss you crazy
very true like if you see someone i
don't want a crazy
woman then you're like yeah i like this
guy
i'm better than all those other girls
and you know
i'll show him i hate them all yeah i'll
kill him
i'll kill them i kill them
like that where it was just like um you
have the ball saved
hold on no it's i just googled this oh
that's good but there is
one that i've seen that was like yeah
women are so blah blah i'm not hero here
we go here we go um
let me zoom zoom z uh
he said what he doesn't like in profiles
not here for hookups blah blah real man
i've gone balls deep and a handful of
females with such profiles
you next oh my god they're just
listening things they'd hate about women
yeah because this is what i don't want
yeah um or if you have
my fur kids come first it says every mom
on tinder
um yeah it's just they just listening
like they they're like attacking
women yeah yeah like oh if you're if
you're just a bimbo that's looking for
blah blah blah
swipe blah blah blah i'm looking for
someone who's this and that and like
yeah yeah like a [ __ ] bag yeah yeah it
sounds like he never got over his ex
yeah right yeah if you have brown hair
green eyes
yeah you need to get the [ __ ] off yeah
if you have to like
complain to the like before the dates
even started
then you're not ready to date i think
that's the point like you need to take a
break
take a step back yeah yeah detox from
women
that's what i did for men detoxing it's
been [ __ ] like 10 months since i've
had sex
make it to that year almost there
and it's and it helps a lot it helps a
lot are there ones that's like
that have like i don't want any one of
the cricket teeth so
oh yeah [ __ ] your crooked teeth [ __ ]
you'll never get a date in this town
if you got crooked teeth candid can help
you out so candid are these clear
comfortable removable practically
invisible aligners to help
straighten your teeth my son like i've
talked about over and over again he is
currently wearing braces
and it is not pleasant he does not like
him he's not having a good time with
them i'm sorry
my dude but that's what you that's those
are just the cards you got dealt with
but not you out there who want to fix
your teeth
you can be getting candid like i said
they're super
easy they're removable you don't get all
that gunk stuck in your wires or
the brackets that you have because you
don't have those wire
super expensive traditional tray braces
candid
is uh is more affordable it costs
thousands
less than traditional braces and the
average candid treatment is just six
months and you'll start seeing results
way before then
the cool thing is that with candid they
use the they use
only orthodontist other companies they
will use
general dentists but candid only works
for orthodontist and
the same orthodontist that created your
treatment
plan it will be there from start to
finish so you'll never have to wonder
how you're doing
and with your liner treatment you'll get
candids teeth whitening for
free candid can help you get the
straighter brighter smile you've always
wanted
right now you can save 75 on your candid
starter kit
when you get started from home or you
can book an appointment at a candid
studio near you today
go to candidco.com mood
use code mood that's candidco.com
mood code mood take advantage of this
limited time offer to save
75 on your starter kit candidco.com
mood code mood and fix those crooked
teeth um i also want to shout out our
sponsor
noom because okay like jess said
hot vac summer is happening and everyone
wants to get in shape
but crash diets do not work okay you're
just gonna gain back
all the weight then some probably more
yeah probably more
i've done them all by the way like like
your body is like
history too you do your body gets so
unbalanced your gut health gets thrown
off
you just like you don't know how to your
body doesn't know how to process things
anymore
instead you can use a psychology-based
approach to help you change your mindset
for good
because building better habits means a
more sustainable journey to better
health
so you know sometimes for me
i would be in a social situation and i
would grab snacks right away because it
was kind of like a security and i didn't
really
know that i was doing that you know when
you look at a food journal i wouldn't
count those snacks as something that
i was consuming because i forgot that i
did that i was doing it out of anxiety
exactly and i would do that when i was
stressed or when i was trying to
procrastinate i would grab
snacks um so changing that psychology
really helps in developing
better habits a healthier life doesn't
mean sticking to someone else's strict
rules it means
having a more having more knowledge to
build smarter more sustainable habits
so noom's cognitive behavioral approach
focuses on why
instead of what to help you change your
relationship with food
and everybody's journey looks different
noom customizes a program for you based
on your personal goals
and eighty percent of new users finish
the program and over
sixty percent have stuck with their
goals for at least a year that's a
huge ratio of people that have stuck
with their goals
so start building better habits for
healthier long-term results sign up for
your trial at
noom.com big mood again sign up for your
trial at noom.com
big mood that's n-o-o-m.com slash
big mood whoa yeah this is fun i'm
having fun googling worst tinder
profiles
yeah oh my god yeah one of those guys
strangling this girl in his
profile picture oh for some like bdsm
yeah
i think that what we should do is like
see
if our viewers will submit their
profiles to us on instagram
and we can approve and we can go through
them like we can edit keep it we can
still keep it anonymous or like cover
your face like black out your face or
something but like in your name
and all that location and all that but
like still just go through it will help
eddie
write your bio and then you can get
advice from because i think reddit does
that right like you can i think i've
seen
threads on reddit where they're like
rate my profile and they like get
advice from like the general reddit
community like a great idea
or bad so i feel like that'd be fun for
us if we tried it and good for you for
one wanting uh another eye yeah to get
another eyes
yeah looking to feel the void left
behind by the death of my mother
wow oh whoa yeah i want to swipe on that
for sure
no [ __ ] way hell are you my mommy
are you are you my new mommy will you
wipe my butt and pay for all my things
you want a grilled cheese sandwich
please
there's no woman in my kitchen i need to
put another woman in there
oh geez that is so unattractive yeah
yeah i just want to keep looking at them
because i've already seen something you
already listed off with emojis
there's this one and this one bothers me
too okay when i see this one i go
ugh i can picture that very simple
though
it's very simple don't waste her [ __ ]
time
it's very simple it's when putting in
your profile
just ask me oh yeah yeah oh
they're going to fill out nothing and
they say
just ask that's not going to work
instant swipe left yeah
i'm like can you put in 10 minutes of
thought to kind of tell me who you are
right if you can't even do that you
definitely won't [ __ ] need my [ __ ]
there's a difference between being
mysterious and like yeah and no effort
at all no effort i just i can't stand
the zero effort thing
and that's for me just i i'm literally i
know it's tender but maybe even on hinge
or like the other ones
i will aggressively swipe left but they
would just ask me
like just write a sentence yeah like
obviously you don't know anything about
me either like i just wrote a sentence
about myself i didn't hear you go like
no no yeah or like or like when they
or they they if you do match with them
and they message you first and all they
say is
hi yeah i think they're i think because
there's so many like bots on the dating
sites like for the on the women's side
that guys are like is this even a person
oh really yeah i think they don't
believe that you're even a person you
sound like a bot when you just say hi
yeah wait they have bots on dating sites
oh yeah it's a big scam
by the way catfishing to get money
probably also it makes guys think that
there's like actually
like because okay oh right the problem i
have with dating apps i'm gonna get just
for one second is that
women are the commodity like we are
what's being sold on a dating app that's
why
bumble i'm not a huge fan of that we'll
never get them as a sponsor probably
after me saying this but like
it's a woman that owns it but and it's
like four women or whatever like women
are the ones who swipe
on the men and messages get to message
them first and all that but it's still
like
women are this commodity yeah and so
like
to keep guys to keep paying for profiles
they're basically like
creating fake bot accounts so guys think
that like women are active on here and
there's like a marketplace for them
we are the marketplace so there's a ton
of bot issues it's just like instagram
it's like yeah that makes sense but even
in real life dating
world like going to the club you know a
lot of hot girls getting free so that
yeah
like what the guys are coming there and
that's why they'll pay for drinks right
overpriced drinks and all that [ __ ]
so anyway
um okay i want to know what you guys put
on your profiles
i've sent you guys remember i did like a
video when i had a hinge profile like a
couple years ago
um i sent a video of it that was anyone
that would like ask questions and you
would answer the questions right yeah
there's like problems
what about what about like just like if
you had a bio that you had to fill out
um yeah i don't know well because that
one that one was just like it asks you
things like texting girl with a
california heart oh my god
that's hilarious my heart my heart
belongs oh my state
i only like two cents in california but
left my heart in texas
i'm in texas but i left my heart yeah
yeah now that you know yeah
every time i move i just switch it i
have a heart attack
i remember putting on my profile if
you're the type of person that loves
going hiking waking up early and going
to the gym
and working out
no i'm not yeah yeah yeah i like cheetos
and video games don't expect
anything out of me yeah like naps and
video games yeah
nice maybe you need someone like that in
your life though yeah i think you need
someone to
help get you you know the guys like fun
thing for him is like training for a 10k
marathon it's like
what if he doesn't pressure you to do it
oh yeah i'll show you one on this one
yeah
yeah that's fine yeah being a good
influencer
that was kind of what i meant those guys
still though they kind of make you feel
guilty for not being on their level so
it's still
that's a you like issue for i know you
know what you got but you know when they
walk through the room they're like okay
i'm going for my 10 mile hike and you're
still
like playing video games they're like
okay i'm going for my hike and you're
like
okay then it's just kind of like a weird
energy
no it's not weird but were you saying
that it reminded me of casey
because casey's been going on hikes
every morning so he'll wake me up be
like hey do you want to join me on my
hike
i'm like nope no i'm going on my house
you probably should go on
ice i probably should no but i've been
doing my high yoga okay i know okay
you're killing it now when people say
that like oh you're just gonna play
games all day like yup i make money off
of it yeah yeah
for you it makes sense yeah for most
people they don't make money yeah
they just think that maybe one day they
will but sorry joe that's not the real
dream
joe is just a random joe blow name okay
i didn't mean
like jonathan's playing video games at
all sorry
statistically my ex is gonna be named
joe like there's just so many yeah
um there's a lot of joes yeah i've been
killing it
here's one been playing a lot of games
but i'll do it on the treadmill oh sorry
i was just thinking about how many games
how much games i play lately
nice oh because you're doing it while
you're working well that's yeah doing
something
i need a game where i can like don't
have to sit still and play because i
can't
shoot while running my aim's all over
the place
i know that there is a i remember seeing
a game
that it only lets you play if it's being
powered up with you like
doing the bicycle [ __ ] oh it's like that
black mirror episode where that's how
they
oh my god yeah maybe i'm sure i got it
from i should make a computer program
where it won't
power your computer unless you're
cycling yeah i think that's the thing
that i saw
and you're hydration levels it's
dehydrated a black mirror is it black
mirror maybe
yeah that's not real no because i
remember it was like a sit down one
black mirror is like yours
it's like it's like this one and the
black mirror was like a bite it was like
a bicycle so
it was definitely a different product i
don't know okay
um another thing that a guy should not
put in his profile or if he does it's an
obvious red flag
um keep me in check when i lose my cool
oh
no you're just letting i mean
some of these i'm like go ahead and put
that in there so i know to swipe left on
you
because you obviously have to filter
yourself out yeah
be my mother basically discipline me
yeah i can't control myself but you
you yeah it's your responsibility when i
[ __ ]
rage down the freeway while we're
fighting and i put your life in danger
it's like
no thanks go ahead and keep that on your
profile if you wrote it
yep um and then okay one more
um not my kid in the picture i
hate that too they always they try to
bait women with little
little dangly things and one of them is
babies but they're not even their own
babies they're
my sister's baby or my puppy puppy yeah
i'm like
get out of here like where's your
personality why do you have to dangle a
baby
exactly like that's the only thing i
want isn't it does that really work
for me it doesn't but she doesn't it
shows girls that this is a sensitive sex
he's like
look little tiny fragile things can be
around me and not get murdered
i guess it does tap into like the the
biological
like the nurturing yeah i think it's all
we have you know how they
say like when a guy gets married
when a guy gets married he has a baby
and he like takes the baby up for a walk
then like all the neighborhood moms are
like
oh yeah whatever you know like it's just
you see a married man or a man with a
baby and he becomes more attractive
instantly even though he's not single or
available anymore
damn so they're like the opposite
happens to me that's what i'm like what
is it like
to for it to be attractive because for
me i'm like
like oh you're not a sexual being
anymore yeah same
yeah i mean it's very um it's just that
animal
instinct of like oh he's a woman has
approved of him first of all
which is a good sign if another woman
has approved them generally
not always and he's taking care of them
yeah and he's doing he's being
responsible he's being responsible and
he's providing for
like that's just our instinct to like
want to procreate and if he's willing to
provide for one then
he's a valuable one right so they're
kind of faking that by putting someone
else's kid in their profile yeah
i'm just like oh just whatever yeah if i
see that too not my kid in the pic i'm
like swipe left
because i'm just an [ __ ] anyway but
all right let's switch to some of the
girls dating profiles oh you know what's
really interesting when they post the
picture it's like
if a guy posts a picture with like it's
him and a friend
and his and the friend is very
attractive yeah and you can't tell which
one it is
you don't look further and you're like
oh this guy's hot how does that suppose
that's not gonna work out for you right
like it's you should pose next to uglier
guys
exactly just make yourself look better
find your bald friend
yeah or if you are the bald friend find
an ugly or fatter friend or something i
don't know you're a short friend find a
shorter friend yeah i don't know
and then there's like angry guys who are
like oh you you you're only out here for
looks then that's why women are so
shallow
if you guys just know my personality
then you know you want to care about the
projections
they just want the heart yeah that's the
same thing though
but human nature looks is what brings us
in first like that's
you know like that's attractiveness
profile
i would click on you but if you're just
angry
yeah yeah you're bitter i think it taps
into that primitive stuff that we're
talking about too
when it's like attractiveness like
you're looking for a good looking
partner because then you think that
they're healthier
they're stronger they're they don't have
like messed up genes diseases yeah the
jeans are
good and they give your babies better
jeans so that they can keep on
procreating and stuff yeah yeah so sorry
if you're
butt ugly that's [ __ ] up
it's like that with casting too um with
tv shows like they've tried having
less traditionally attractive leads and
the viewership drops because like people
are just
like that like just on a subconscious
level like they just want to watch
pretty people
i'm trying to think i feel like there's
shows that i've seen without the
the scrubby guys have been coming back
coming in a trend like over the past 10
years like the leading man
has become more scrubby and like more
like uh seth rogen than
like bad brad pitt but um the women
they still have to stay pretty even like
the
quirky ones are still very attractive
and like
it's weird i guess if they're the big
girl then they're like the hottest one
that they
you know or whatever that's not
conventionally attractive it's still
like the hottest one of whatever this
yeah like of the nerd girls or the
whatever girls yeah there's i mean
there's probably some exceptions but
yeah that's probably sure there's
probably all
there's always exceptions but yeah yeah
like a steve bush
man yeah there's a lot of really ugly
secondary characters
that's where they the supporting
character that's where they stay that's
where they are
all right well um let's move on to girls
profiles so
this was just a list guys reveal things
women shouldn't put on dating profiles
um let's see i hate when girls dating
profile contains pictures that are all
grouped oh that was what you were yeah
there you go
am i supposed to guess which one she is
if i've ever had uh
i've used a group photo before but i
kind of use the blur tool on everyone's
face
on my own so you can like obviously you
can only see it's me but
it was just like a picture that i really
love or crop out
people around you yeah but it also makes
sense like why you would want to put a
group photo because
it's like hey look i have friends yeah i
have a life like i'm not going to rely
on you for 24 7 everything like i have
friends
i feel like that's a positive thing
maybe it's like a third or fourth yeah
exactly
yeah not the first or second one yeah
towards the end because you get like
eight photos or something on a lot of
them so
at this point if people start like if
what the [ __ ]
your brain is this is really mean but
like
imagine like from now on if i ever see
like a group photo and then it turns out
it's not the cute guy
just to teach him a lesson i'm gonna
message him and be like hey i just swipe
and just be like hey
um does your friend have an instagram
you know like that's
there now you'll learn your lesson stop
putting group photos of like people who
are more judgmental just
photos just to bait people in you know
or blur them like would you yeah
just blur their face there's a blur tool
in like so many different you know photo
editing apps that
you don't have to i don't know people
don't put that much thought into it i
guess
um all right the next one is i love when
girls say
obviously that's sarcasm on a dating app
that they're on a dating app because
their friend made them do it so it's
like the same company
yeah that's the other one don't mind
excuses you're on this app because
you're long
everyone else yeah exactly this is like
those people there's a subway called
oops didn't mean to
and it's filled with people who like
clearly took it as a selfie yeah
they're like oh oops uh my camera fell
for some reason i took a photo
while i'm down i would never post these
yeah just like it's one of those like oh
yeah i didn't you know my friend made me
do it that's
like very important just own up to it
you take a [ __ ] selfie it's a nice
one feeling yourself
yeah yeah yeah and they come up like the
funniest excuses like
oops my son was holding this phone of
mine he just took this photo of me
posing yeah
like they're all [ __ ] just own it
dude that's funny
just makes you seem more insecure when
you put you yeah exactly exactly
obviously
guys highlighting your insecurities yeah
you can't like
agree with what you want to do so much
yeah here's
here's one um so many girls put must be
six to or must be six foot or taller on
their profiles
so guys can output must be 100 pounds or
less
it's only fair exactly because it's more
[ __ ] up i don't think any
woman is 100 pounds i know but i'm
saying like in general you know like
okay
like if you're gonna tell men you have
to be this
much this physically yeah physical
things you can't control then you should
be able to tell you okay
well you can still have a preference
right but you don't have to say it's
like
if i have a preference and my preference
is 5 10 or up so then i don't need to
advertise that it'll just
it'll just not happen naturally in my
like oh i'm like oh he's five six oh
yeah yeah i've dated guys that are five
six so you know it doesn't really matter
that much but
if that's my preference then i'll just
naturally do that but like you don't
have to advertise saying that
it's like very unnecessary it's like
showing that you think you
are better than anyone that's under six
foot the joke here
was that the guy that the guy who said
this responded said are you looking for
a boyfriend are you trying to get dunked
on
i thought that was funny it's like it's
more messed up for guys because
women can change their weight it's more
like saying like
men can change their height women only
with blue eyes yeah like
something you can't change yeah yeah
about yourself yeah oh i remember one of
my ex-boyfriends said he liked back
dimples on a girl like you know those
bags
and i don't have them and i was like i
took it i was like really offended yeah
yeah because i could never get back so
then i started being like oh i really
like all these guys that are super tall
because
yeah well i don't even care about height
yeah in fact i'm
my husband is six four and i feel like
it's it's kind of a hindrance because
he's so
tall up there like he's a foot taller
than me it's very high to kiss it hurt
my neck
of dating like this all the time he
always has to be sitting down
he has to either squat or like straddle
like his legs so he's shorter
and i have to be on tippy toes we've
worked it out since but it was really
difficult he's like kissing you in the
hallway and his feet are touching both
sides of the wall
so you can get down low he also does the
like straight ahead straddle yeah
there you go straight head straddle
that's a good lunge yeah and split two
ways
but you know what it all feels the same
horizontal and boy do we have a
comfortable mattress
you ever want to lay horizontal with
this have you ever been four man
on a purple mattress perhaps yeah you
want to do it on a purple mattress
doesn't it seem like the world's against
us from getting a good night's sleep
this time of year
i know it's been hot as hell i
toss and turn i got the ac crank down
but you know what it's so hot outside
the ac ain't even doing [ __ ]
and i'm just sweating in my sleep and my
dogs are licking their lips because
they're thirsty and it's just hot
and i can't get any good sleep but you
know what when you have a purple
mattress you can sleep cool and
comfortable no matter what the world
throws at you
uh the purple mattress has a grid it is
a comfort reinvented only purple has
the grid a stretchy gel material that's
amazingly supportive for your back and
legs while cushioning your shoulders
neck and hips
i don't know how it does it but it's
just fantastic it's just a very unique
bed i've never seen one like it before
the grid bounces back as you move and
shift unlike memory foam which remembers
everything
that's why memory foam has craters and
divots and right now you can try your
purple mattress risk free with
free shipping and returns financing is
available too
purple is comfort reinvented right now
you'll get 10
off any order of two hundred dollars or
more go to purple.com slash big mood 10
and use promo code big mood 10. that's
purple.com
big mood 10 promo code big mutant for 10
off any order of 200 or more purple.com
big mood 10 promo code big mood 10 terms
apply i know that when you order
uh bed a bed from them too they might
throw in a few things for you too and
they have like all these sets and stuff
which is really cool
great companies our next sponsor early
adopter our next sponsor
ladies is raycon pay attention because
these earbuds are actually really good
oh yeah they're really good they sent us
to them they sent us a pair each to us
i can't speak english
and um i was like okay whatever i'll use
these as my backup ones but
i've actually been selecting them a lot
more because the battery life
yes it's amazing insane on the recons
like they last so
much longer i don't have to put them
back in and charge them like i can go
six hours like i can go a long time in
my day doing
tasks i just moved into my new apartment
so i was like unpacking unpacking like
doing all that stuff and of course i
gotta have the music on
so i i wore them and i was surprised the
battery life they connect super fast to
my phone like i was like are these going
to be good enough for the iphone they
are
yeah they actually are they connect
really easily it's great very nice
packaging too yeah i love it i like the
little case
yeah oh it's so cute what color did you
guys get red yeah i got red too
i also like i got blue was the only one
yeah the only one that got blue
yeah it's like the color of nikki's
nails oh yeah yeah they're blue in the
color of gina's nails it's really cute
i also like that the shape of them
they're round and they kind of sit more
inside of your ear so like when i take
my hoodie on and off it doesn't get
caught
and like like fall out so that's another
pro on those
you can get crisp powerful beats at half
the price of other premium audio brands
i believe that the sound is great on
them they're they're totally i was legit
going to buy one of those expensive
brands yeah i was considering it
and that are like 300 yeah yeah or more
yeah um but then after getting these
raycons i'm like i'm set
yeah i don't need them and also if if
you happen to lose or damage one then
you don't have to feel so bad about it
yeah because they are
little teeny tiny pieces of whatever you
know racons look great and feel even
better they come in a range of cool
colors with customizable gel tips
included for a customizable comfortable
in-ear fit
raycons are built to go wherever you go
with quick and seamless bluetooth
pairing and a compact charging case the
seamless bluetooth pairing is true i've
i've i've been very impressed by that
listen up raycon's offering 15
off all their products for our listeners
here's what you got to do to get it go
to buy raycon.com
big mood there you'll get 15 off your
entire
recon order and it's such a good deal
you want to grab a pair
and a spare i want a spare i know i want
some more
that's 15 off at buy recon dot com slash
big mood
buy recon dot com slash big mouth big
mood
anyway so let's move on ladies what else
should we not be putting in our
dating profile this guy said i don't get
why girls make duck faces
oh profile picks for dinner they still
do that there's the puppy one on there
too the puppy filter
oh yeah i swear like so many people made
the puppy filter their profile picture
even on just regular
social media and i'm just like it does i
get that it smooths out all your
features and gives you like a cute face
covering your nose but it covers
everything about you so you all look the
same just like seeing
eyes and a puppy dog face but yeah the
duck face i feel like i don't know if
people are still
doing that but if they are and this is
gonna sound offensive but it's the
people that still spend a lot of time on
facebook because they haven't really
quite caught up with like rumors how
social media has changed and you know
yes still doing the myspace angle from
like way up by the ceiling
like those are they're just not really
kind of with it and that's
i think that's what's more embarrassing
is like you haven't realized that we've
moved on from that
you know so like don't duck face yeah
just smile or whatever the other one
fish face the like
like the fish face one like a fake model
faces
i'm like trying to make fish mouth with
my lips what's the difference between
fish and duck
duck is like more like oh
i see i see with your lips like that
yeah
i don't know i don't really have lips to
be putting in these weird [ __ ]
contortions so maybe that's why i try to
avoid
that oh like they're girls like me that
don't have an upper lip are trying to
like
make it look like they're having a
problem maybe i i'm definitely guilty of
duckface back in 2007.
yeah yeah everyone did this yeah yeah
for sure everyone followed that
pretty sure there's a photo it's over
now i'm still guilty of the
chinese tourists oh yeah sometimes i
like that one
the heart one oh yeah yeah this is my
go-to yeah
it is so asian but it's also still cute
it's not annoying you know
um okay i hate how girls lie about their
age to get older guys
i didn't know that was that really a
problem what is it wait so
younger girls are lying to be older yeah
or older girls lying to be younger
oh yeah no it says i hate how girls lie
about their age to get older guys i
asked my sister why she was dating a 30
year old i found out her age on her
profile says
she's 28 but she just turned 20. watch
out for the jail
boys scary you should not be
[ __ ] saying you're eight years
different than you know that's crazy
why why because then if it gets serious
then it's like your relationship started
on a lie
exactly that's really weird first of all
could potentially be illegal
i guess if you're saying you're 18 when
you're not yeah so
that's a little scary i mean that one
i've heard and that one not being a yeah
being a minor and doing that for sure
but
it's 20 20 yeah it's not even 20.
illegal to drink
oh right yeah so if you want a date and
he's like i'm gonna buy you a drink and
you're not
how are you gonna
also don't date guys [ __ ] 10 years
older than you just
don't get me started um okay here's
another one girls if you skew over your
filter wait if you skew or over filter
your profile pics
don't expect guys to deal with it well
when you don't look the same in person
you're basically lying
everyone does that yeah like i've seen
guys and girls but there's way too many
filters
way too much like i've seen a guy that i
dated once he showed me a picture of
another girl she had done the
you know like ins or no face tune has
the thing where you can like kind of
change your body shape a little bit like
kind of used a little like tuck in here
tuck in there but she like did it so
much where like her body
i have a friend that looks like she
didn't have ribs or something i'm like
you're not on every picture
what the [ __ ] she made herself look like
a victoria's secret model like full on
like the
toys and this was before filters like
this was back when you had to photoshop
all that so people weren't really
hyped to the fact that her body was so
her whole
image was so different and um and so
yeah she would get really confused why
guys wouldn't come back for a second
date oh my goodness
because i think she got so used to
seeing herself look like that and she
was always like well this is what i'm
gonna look like when i get plastic
surgery
and she never got plastic surgery but
like she would always say that like well
this is what i'm gonna look like
and yeah i think like she really
started believing that she looked like
that or something i think the hard part
is like because we know everything on
instagram is kind of fake and filtered
and adjusted and like so
even when you switch over to a dating
app now then if you see
someone like that looks real maybe it's
jarring because like people are so used
to seeing filtered and fake and like
best angles and everything so it's just
really hard for people to put up just an
actual
photo of you untouched no filter no
[ __ ] photoshop
yeah and so i think we have to kind of
get back to a place where we can just
put a photo up
of us that doesn't smooth even your
phones
like a lot of phones like have like a
built-in auto smoother thing
yeah i remember my mom was like my
android phone takes such great pictures
look at my face i was like
it looks like a clown yeah it looks like
a cloud that's an auto
she's like no it's on him like i turned
off like there you go
there's all your wrinkles she's like oh
like yeah
have fun with that yeah because she was
like she was one of those moms that
would not
shut up about well i'm android and
you're all iphone
oh right camera i'm like all right let
me tell you yeah
i don't like the android the samsung's
or whatever that have that auto because
it
just looks like a collab it looks really
bad like i can see that
imagine then like in asia because you
know how in asia oh yeah girls photoshop
they just glow
it's not even that but they're so good
with makeup yeah so how does that work
oh right
it's like photoshopping a baby like a
baby's face is already
yeah i've seen i've i've seen a couple
women like that did you photoshop your
babies oh god their baby has a pointy
ass nose
that's sad leave the baby alone the baby
alone
yeah don't do the baby if anything
that's not that we have to say that
right don't filter your face your baby
damn that's funny they're like i want it
to look like me with all these fake
features that i why your baby got lashes
yeah that's so funny did you see that
one um
that one that was going around on
instagram or tick tock or whatever this
girl that she
photoshop's teeth onto her baby yeah so
funny so funny she's so funny she does
it as a joke
yeah it was a joke there was one where
they were photoshopping smiles onto
eminem pictures
it's really funny i want to do that
it's really funny smiles on him
it's like when they photoshop dogs with
full teeth oh yeah that's so
good hilarious for eyebrows yeah that's
the best part of the internet
there's this joke on tik tok where like
um i'm gonna
it's like a picture of two girls right
and she's like i'm gonna send this
picture to my friend and ask her if it's
okay to post
but she like slightly moved her friend's
eye a little bit
and then she says it to her she goes can
i post this and the girl's like
her friend's like no what the [ __ ] is
going on
and then she's like what what's wrong
she goes i look like santa's sloth
because my friend that did the photoshop
stuff she would always just photoshop
her soft and group pictures and leave
everyone else so everyone else gets
fabulous yes yeah because they would she
would use the liquid tool to make her
skinny so if you're standing next to her
it drags
their bellies out oh no yeah we have a
rule in this group we don't both control
this
[Applause]
yeah you got to be a good friend and
just like fix everyone up you know yeah
be that person but it's funny then if
someone you send someone
your photoshop version they're like hey
i like it
myself why did you everybody said about
me yeah that's why i don't mess with
that that's tricky
like tricky i know what you guys like
yeah at least we talked about it i
do kind of i i do wonder sometimes too
like if you fix someone else you're like
what the [ __ ] do you like yeah
oh so you don't like my nose yeah you
had to fix my nose yeah
yeah i just don't like my belly button
to show through my shirt like if you
just like
just like patch that out yeah you have
no belly button
no through the shirt doesn't show the
indentation i have a really deep belly
button i'm very
so it looks like a hole in your shirt
yeah i don't like it like sometimes it
peeps out of my shirt where like
it's like hello it's like a
you see it more on people that are kind
of big like when you're when you have
a big belly feel like i look like a
crater where you're
that's funny it's really interesting to
see what little things people notice
about their bodies
never remember like just looking at that
i mean just as you had pointy elbows
like what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah i'm like i got sharp [ __ ]
elbows you gotta pull those in
um okay here's another one i don't know
what's also though what those are the
girls that
they they post pictures where everyone
else is clearly like half blink
yeah whatever and everyone else is like
[ __ ] she looks great yeah but she's
still posting like
[ __ ] those [ __ ] that's rude
except for one time i remember we posted
when
all the girls on jk we did a girls
episode we were all making silly faces
but jesus was particularly silly yeah
and i did one where i zoomed in yeah i
was not too happy about that
she actually got mad at it i was like
what the [ __ ]
but it was supposed to do that it made
me laugh so hard
this is so good oh my gosh yeah
that's funny she's like i have my place
i have my days where i'm okay with it
and my day's working
oh wait i think i know which one we were
all making silly faces it was a silly
face photo
but mine was like particularly [ __ ]
gross
she had like five chins yeah
it was a halfway like not ready photo
yeah it was like no
why why do you hate me i loved you the
most
i love one night i show love you know
those those those sites that talk about
like
people like celebrities and stuff or
like even youtubers they're like well
she looks like this on her instagram
photo but she looks like yeah like
they're halfway blinking
how h3 did that yeah remember when h3
did that about trisha paytas
he did a whole video of like instagram
versus instagram versus reality
oh [ __ ] it totally blew her out of the
water i was like but i think it's
particularly like you have to choose a
picture of them like half blinking like
not even
she was
um pages that are like celebrities in
real life where they like turn the
clarity like way up or whatever
yeah they also manipulated to make them
look uglier exactly that's what i'm
saying
or and they also use these they'll use
pictures now and then compare them with
like ones 15 years ago
it's like the in the actual celebrity
sometimes comment like that was from 15
years ago yeah i'm like 15 years older
now
i've gained more weight like that
doesn't make sense for
changes over 15 years yeah it has to
make sense yeah that makes sense like if
it's a picture of someone that's
clearly this is like same day yeah like
this was from a
healthy from a photographer this was
this event from someone else's phone
yeah the same day it's a different did
you see like uh what's her name chloe
khloe kardashian
terrible thing where she was in a
bathing suit and like her belly popped
out a little bit
more because of the position she wasn't
even that bad it really wasn't bad but
but um but yeah like the the internet
made it into a big old thing like she
photoshopped her body and then she had
to come out and like
she did a whole video like see this is
my body i'm not photo oh but you know
what
you know the real t i saw that that
video
was also a filtered video because
yeah i was watching different um not
tick tocks but reels
reels uh where this girl was showing
like this
this felt video filter that makes you
look like super
skinny it looks really real like i would
be hella tricked by it
and then she showed it with that off and
it's like whoa her body just morphs
yeah that's crazy i do that a lot on in
like in asia
yeah because you didn't change your
background at all yeah oh wow yeah it
was like
really good yeah there's video filtering
apps that are really good okay well we
got to wrap up soon but i just wanted to
throw another couple in there
this guy said thank you to the girls who
put i want a rich guy on their dating
profile because i know immediately you
won't make a good partner which that's
true that's like the anchor is [ __ ]
scary
yeah and then uh you know what kills me
girls who have a dating profile and one
of their picks is a butt shot talk about
trashy so
if you are trying to get a well don't
look a good guy don't put don't look at
her
exactly you just you get whole results
yeah so if you're
aware of your whole results and that's
your it's the
equivalent that was your hope yeah
like you know what gets you the results
you want like if you had say put ask
about wine
yeah don't get mad because i didn't send
you
right away i only want nudes yeah nudes
in exchange for wine
transparent yeah what have you
wasted your [ __ ] what if i didn't
have unlimited data [ __ ] wasted my
time on my data
well anyway um i think that we should
try to
try to see if our audience will engage
yes your dating profile will you guys
let us rate your dating profiles if we
promise to keep you anonymous still
block out your name yeah location
and we can blind yeah so um let's try
that we'll
call we'll do a call it on instagram so
follow us on big mood girls
on instagram and also please visit our
sponsors
that is the biggest way you can help the
show um the second biggest way is to
rate us on itunes
subscribe like share videos whatever all
that stuff you know um anyways
thank you guys thanks bye next week